皆さんはゲームと聞いてどのような印象を
持ちます
か楽しいありがとうございますまゲームと
聞いて残念なことに多くの大人はゲームが
悪影響を及ぼすものだっていう風に考えて
いますで実際にそういったことを表す言葉
としてゲーム能という言葉がありますこれ
はゲームのことばかりを考えてしまって
生活に支障をきたしてしまった人のことを
指しますひょっとすると僕もその1人なの
かもしれないなという風に最近は思って
ます僕は子供の頃からたくさんのゲームを
プレイしてきましたスマブラポケモン
ゼルダの伝説いろんなメジャータイトルを
プレイしてきましたでままそういった様子
を見て学校の先生はゲームばっかりしない
で宿題をしなさいゲームのになりますよと
いう風に言われていたのですでも実際今
考えてみるとその学校の先生の言っていた
ことは当たっていたんじゃないかなという
風に思いますなぜなら今ここで皆さんに
ゲームの素晴らしさをお話ししていますし
大学院の方でゲームの研究をしているから
です今ゲームの素晴らしさと言いましたが
皆さんはゲームの素晴らしさをどのように
お考えです
か多分たくさんの答えがあると思うんです
けどもまず1つ代表的なのがゲームが我々
の予価を充実させてくれるものであると
いうことは明らかだと思いますそれに加え
て僕はもう1つゲームがリアルと
バーチャルをつぐ掛け橋になっているいる
んじゃないのかなという風に思っています
その掛け橋を作るために僕は様々な活動を
行っていますそしてそこで特に使っている
のがMinecraft
ですMinecraftというゲームを
聞いたことがある人はどれくらいいますか
もたくさんの方が知ってらっしゃいますね
ありがとうございますま簡単に説明します
とmcraとはデジタル版のレゴブロッ
クって言われるようにゲームの中で
ブロックを積み重ねて建物や街を作ったり
するそんなゲームになってます
Minecraftはとても世界で有名な
ゲームであって世界の累計販売本数これ
ゲーム市場1位の2億本を超えているん
ですねこのような特徴があるmcraです
がそれがどのようにリアルとバーチャルを
つなぐ掛け橋になっているのか今回はその
リアルでもありバーチャルでもあるマ
ラフトの世界に皆さんをご紹介したいと
思い
ますまず初めにMinecraftがどの
ようにして教育に使われているのか
Minecraftには教育版
Minecraftというバージョンが
ありますこれは学校やプログラミング
スクールでも活用されているものですじゃ
なぜMinecraftが教育によって
使われているの
かその答えの1つはMinecraftが
あらゆる学習の入り口になるという風に
考えられているからです例えば
プログラミング的思考力についてお話しし
てみ
ましょうはい教育版Minecraftに
はメイクコードと呼ばれるプログラミング
をパズル感覚で楽しむことができるツール
が用意されています例えば皆さんがお子
さんにプログラミングの本を購入してあげ
たとしますそれでプロプログラミングを
学習してみなさいそう言ったとしても自分
から本を開いて勉強するという人は少ない
と思いますしかしマイクラのメイクコード
使えばもっと効率的に簡単に建物作れるよ
そんな風にお子さんに言うとみんなこの
メイクコードを楽しんで使い始めていつの
間にかプログラミング的思考力が身につい
ているということがあるんですねこのよう
にまminecを通じてリアルでも活用
できるスキルを身につつけることができる
バーチャルとリアルをつなぐ掛け橋をまず
ここでMinecraftが作っています
また別の例を見てみ
ましょうこれは僕が関わったプロジェクト
の1つである宮城県にある上農業高校の
Minecraftのプロジェクトです
ここの学校では自分たちの学校の農場
こちらをmcraで再現するという
プロジェクトに取りかかりましたその中で
生徒たちはとても貴重な体験を数多くする
ことができました例えばどうすればこの
mcraの世界に訪れた人たちが楽しんで
学校を探検することができるのかどうすれ
ば協力して効率的にmcraftで生作
することができるのかあらゆることを考え
ましたまた同様にこのワールドに訪れる
ことができたのは北海道から九州まで様々
な地域からこのワールドの見学に来てくれ
ました彼らもまた普段は行けない学校の
農場をこのバーチャル世界で探検すること
ができたのですここでもリアルの世界を
バーチャルを通じて体験するMCがリアル
とバーチャルをつぐ駆けになっています
また別の例を見てみましょうこちらは僕が
実施した早稲田大学での
Minecraftの授業です僕がこの左
の写真のMinecraftで早稲田大学
のキャンパスを再現しましたそのワールド
を用いて学生たちに理想のキャンパスを
デザインしてくれとそういった課題を与え
て取りかかってもらいましたここで1つ
面白いのはこの授業に参加したのは建築や
デザインそういった知識を持ってない文系
の学生です文系の学生が普段自分たが利用
している空間をデザインするデザイナー
目線からその空間を捉えることを体験し
ましたリアルで経験しているその世界それ
をバーチャルで作り替えるまたここでも
Minecraftがリアルとバーチャル
をつなぐ掛け橋になっていますまた別の例
を見てみましょうこちらは僕が運営して
いるMinecraftの公式イベントで
あるMinecraftカップです
Minecraftカップはは都市部
そして地方部この間にある教育のレベルの
格差これを何とかするために活動している
団体
ですここでその目的を達成するために
mcraftカップは主に2つのことに
取り組んでい
ます1つ目がmcraカップという名前の
通り大会を開催することです毎年sdgs
に関連するテーマ今年で言えばクリーン
エネルギーそのテーマを子供たちに課題と
して与えますそして子供たちがそれについ
て自分で調査研究をしてそこで得た知識を
mcraの世界で表現して応募してきて
くれます今年で5回目の大会なんですけど
も毎年すごくレベルの高い作品を子供たち
が作って提出してきてくれ
ますまたもう1つmcraカップが行って
いることがありますそれは全国を回って
ワークショップを実施しています例えば昨
年度実施した
ワークショップ去年は廃校の理活用に焦点
を当ててワークショップを実施しました
ワークショップの最初には子供たちはまず
どうして廃校が問題になっているのかどう
して廃校が増えているのかそういった
ところを子供たちは学習しますそしてその
問題の解決の策の1つとして廃校の利己
活用があることを知り
より素晴らしい廃校離活用をするためには
どうすればいいのかっていうところを
グループで考えそれをMinecraft
で表現をするこのワールドにある配向で
挑戦するといったことを目的としています
そのえグループワークメンバーは基本的に
見知らぬ人同士ですしかしそれでも
グループワークを通じて仲が良くなり最終
的に先ほど申し上げた大会の方に
エントリーしてくれるなんていうことも
あり
ますこのような活動をMinecraft
カップは行っていますが
Minecraftカップの意義これは僕
が主に2つ考えています1つ目が
Minecraftをきっかけに子供たち
が学習をするというきっかけになっている
から
です基本大人たちは勉強しなさいそのよう
に子供たちを生やし立てますが子供たちは
その大会に応募するために自分から調べて
調査をして知識を得ますそしてその得た
知識を表現するためにワールドを作るこの
ようにバーチャル世界で自分の知識を表現
するためにリアルで様々なことを学習する
ここでもmcraがリアルとバーチャルを
結ぶ掛け橋になっていますまたもう1つ私
が考えるMinecraftカップの意義
はminecがあらゆる子供たちの輝く
場所になっているということですマイ
クラフトカップのイベントにはなかなか
普段学校に通えないそんな子供たちも度々
参加してくれていますそういった子供たち
が自分のマインクラフトのスキルを存分に
発揮してグループの中で活躍する様子を
よく目にしますしそれを見た保護者の方
がイベントを開催してくれてありがとう
ございますといったような感謝の言葉を
いただくこともでき
ますリアルをリアルでのコミュニティを
バーチャルを通じて広げていくここでも
minecがリアルとバーチャルを結ぶ
駆け足になってい
ますここまでは教育分野を皆さんに特に
紹介してきましたが次は私の専門分野でも
ある街づくりの事例を紹介したいと思い
ますこちらはブラジルのサンパウロにある
とある階段です写真のようにゴミが散乱し
ていたり日々が入っていたりここに雑草が
追いしっていたりさらにこの辺りの地域は
治安がものすごく悪いそういった問題を
抱えていましたこの問題を解決するべく
立ち上がった地域団体がまず行ったのが
市民と行政と協力してこの会談を回収する
ということですその回収のプロジェクトを
達成するために使ったツールとして
クラフトがあります子供たちがmcraを
通じてどのような怪談が理想的なデザイン
かそのデザインについてお互い協力し
ながら作りこのようなデザイアを子供たち
は考えましたこのデザインを元に実際の
会談の設計図を作成して行政と市民が協力
をし次のようなカラフルな階段が生まれた
の
ですすごくこれは面白いプロジェクトだな
と思いまして僕はこの団体にインタビュー
をしてみましたすると面白いことがいくつ
も分かりました例えば今この階段周辺の小
学校に通う子供たちが隙間時間に遊びに
来る怪談が遊び場になっているということ
が分かったのですさらにここの階段今誰が
管理運営しているのかもちろん行政も
関わっていますしかし市民この周りにする
人住む人々もこの管理運営に携わっている
ということが分かりました自分でデザイン
した自分で作ったそういった思いからこの
場所を大事にしたいという気持ちが芽生え
たんですこのサンパウロのような事例は他
にも世界各地で見られます同様な
プロジェクトについて僕はインタビューを
したり事例調査を実施したのですが今お
話ししたようなこの空間を大切にしたい
自分たちの空間だそういった所有者意識を
持っているということがどのプロジェクト
でも見られまし
たバーチャルで自分たちのアイデアを
デザインしてそれをリアルの世界に持って
くるその結果様々な良いポジティブな効果
が生まれている街づくり分野においても
minecがリアルとバーチャルをつぐ
駆け足になってい
ます今回は皆さん
にバーチャルとリアルを結ぶ駆け
whichをMinecraftがどの
ように作っているかという話をしてきまし
た確かにMinecraftは素晴らしい
ツールであるとは思うんですけども同時に
僕は次のようにも考えてい
ますMinecraftが全ての人の人生
を変えるというわけではないMCが全ての
問題を解決できるというわけではない
しかしMinecraftだからこそ人生
が変わる人もいるMinecraftだ
からこそ解決できる問題もある僕はこの
ように考えてい
ます今回はMinecraftに焦点を
当てて皆さんに紹介をしてきましたしかし
これMinecraft以外のゲームでも
同じことが言えると思います
皆さんもゲームを見た時にそれただの
ゲームでしょ何の役に立つの時間の無駄
じゃんそういう風に思うのではなくてどう
すればそのゲームを使えるのかどうすれば
それを社会に活用できるのかそういった
目線を皆さんに持っていただきたいです
これからもえ僕はバーチャルとリアルを
つなぐ掛橋を様々なゲームを用いて作って
いくことを考えています皆さんにも是非
その掛け橋を作っていただきたいさらに
最終的には一緒に社会を変えていけたらな
という風に思いますご清聴ありがとう
ございまし
[拍手]
た